how good is it to get a pentakill at the
LCS osa LCS all-stars it's only three
walks through Europe plus in South
America everyone else's trash and Iran -
everyone else is bad Peter double lift
hang has cemented himself as one of the
most influential ad carry's in league of
legends history with his notorious
trash-talking nature and his
consistently strong play boasting over a
thousand regular-season kills double
list is one of the best League of
Legends players of all time but his
career wasn't always Penta kills and
highlight plays
and that's why the number one bliss
initially known for his Blitzcrank
plague he caught the attention of Jorge
hotshot Gigi Georgia leadeth one of the
most popular streamers in the game and
owner of counter logic gaming one of the
best teams in the world after a short
stint as a sub for CLG ss would leave
and join epic gamer as a support player
playing alongside future team solomid
veteran Markus dyrus Hill the team would
make it to season 1 world championship
falling to the eventual winners fnatic
in the semi finals and taking 4th place
with the tournament over SS was released
from epic gamer his rocky relationship
with his parents would spiral as control
eventually leading to him getting kicked
out of his house with nowhere to go he
turned to the lead community on reddit
and was met with an outburst of support
and he was offered room and board by
Travis Gabbard and interviewer with MLG
and creator of the popular state of the
League podcast and YouTube channel an 18
year old kid out on his own with no life
experience double LIF was forced to
break out of a shell he made money for
rent by writing championship guides for
curse and transition from support to ad
carry after a short stint on team
unrestricted and cursed gaming
doublelift would reunite with counter
logic gaming as their starting ad carry
a move that would end up being the big
break of his career as a professional
gamer alongside some of the biggest
names in the scene doublelift
would have a spotlight on him we talked
about how it was on kind of logic gaming
roster yes that Hugh shot right there
would have actual had doubled it for
them and he's now over on CLG so they
are going to be fighting against each
other at bottom Lane
right now a person a hot Sun did not do
enough damage she does revive Olympus
instead blg can be the third
semifinalist here in the second quarter
now it goes down
that's actually going to be the game
right there there are not dissolve on
CSS and the game and not GOG out of
contention for the World Championship
and though the result didn't necessarily
show it he proved that he was there to
contend for the title as best player in
the world
[Music]
[Applause]
as his playing mechanics received
worldwide praise double its persona as a
confident trash-talker would also get
noticed with them so they're just free
at them you know I'm more scared as far
as coaching honestly syndics winning
against big isn't a huge deal but
stomping a team is definitely it feels
good on stage because you know you found
things in scrims all time I feel a lot
better if we just crashed a luggage CLG
were proved to have too many
personalities causing constant roster
and role swaps that were met with
disappointment
the team had hit rock bottom when they
were forced into relegations with former
teammate big fat gg with their spot and
possibly the team's future on the line I
really just that also if we lose this
the team will not continue I guarantee
I'm pretty scared of losing Russian
delegation of the the worst thing I can
say for the rest of Asia cat CLG with a
3-0 fix will make their way back into
the LCS summer split as one of the few
constants in the roster double it began
to question if he was the reason for CLG
slump in order to shake up the team's
atmosphere CLG would be the first team
in North America to hire a coach I can
trust double if you have insane danger
I'm cool with that it's more about
changing the way the players communicate
to each other
instilling good habits and having them
understand strategy at a very high level
with his newfound support structure
double lips would learn how to
effectively communicate with his
teammate and as the team grew closer
they were finally able to show up on the
big stage
American League Championship Series
dumber file in the turbo for globulin
[Applause]
saving up 40 seconds on the clock boys
and the faithful shall be rewarded I'm
gonna take a trip the world the team
battled hard but once again came up
short when it counted logic game CLG
with their fifties in the first place
cuz that all supported through it an
unsatisfying like for sure but it's also
kind of satisfying to know that we made
so much progress like to go from
relegation to winning at Madison Square
Garden and thrilling TSM our biggest
rivals like we did way better since last
year so I just think you know this guy's
limit and we can do whatever we want
next year and I think we'll succeed with
the domestic success of CLG fans were
optimistic and excited for what the
upcoming season had in store but what
they didn't expect was one of the
biggest offseason shake-up in league of
legends history North America's own
Exodia TSN come I gather they can be
resumed they brought together some of
the best towns across the world yellow
star one of the best parts of the world
double is one of the best city cares
North America tell me is this going to
work out TSM with you big carries in the
roster now it's one of the most hyped up
teams on paper
TSM were clear favorites out of the gate
of the 2016 spring split but not all
things live up to the hype price ticket
have a grow summer he'll use our flashes
one more hitotsu in that first one
double eagle is the hot side it's Alex
ball suspense carry there's the wind for
liquid big reps their seventh win of the
split knocking down TSM this might be
the first time in healthy history where
the North American finals don't include
tetris the team finally came together in
the playoffs upsetting the seemingly
unstoppable any newcomers immortals come
on for taking flooding and damage
separated from the squad and devilís has
picked up why little TSM
to the finals can you believe it on the
back of a three
oh no one would think that gsm would win
it so let alone integrally weep over
immortals who were seventeen and one is
the regular season absolutely incredible
flavor of TSM but just those things were
falling into place
doublelift would fall in the finals to
his former teammates on counter logic
gaming wanted and just get it up like
you had allotted he's so good I read it
all again for the reset these guys
de nada
put it all in his hand give him the
rapid fire give him the reset and give
him his first ever North American
Championship in his first season on CLG
in between the spring and summer split
TSM would retool their roster and take
the risk with a new support they have a
new support in Challenger player bio
frost analyses all eyes about Opera
House where did he pick up from where
yellow for liftoff but they may have
been scary to separate beta 3 members
from that is the game when he played the
cue binding following nubs from file
prods I think Bob Ross Darren 14 the
yellow star and we're going to be really
really good by the end of the slit with
bio frost making quite the debut for
himself doublelift
would once again have the opportunity of
showing his lane dominant nature
now double a part of the spray as well
exhaust is on the bubble but it's not
enough
now that's putting out of ATMs gonna
find some kills already the duo would
solidify themselves as the strongest bot
lane in North America and TSM took the
summer split handily going seventeen and
one breaking a few records along the way
the fastest odds do they turn around for
the kill sponsor fighting
[Applause]
yeah I got positive with us
North American all tells the f-feel
leader settle it with the world
championship on the horizon the team
looked ready to represent North America
on the world stage the team fought
valiantly on the rift but would
eventually fall to the Chinese
powerhouse royal never give up Samsung
County and royal never gave up we'll
move on from Group D and head to that
knockout stage the disappointment on
stage was palpable after looking so
dominant in their regions doublelift had
once again failed to make it past the
group stages at world with all the
intense training and sacrifices made was
it all worth it I'm here bringing you an
announcement bittersweet I'm here today
to announce that I will be taking a
break I'll be trained kissing on staying
with the brand doing everything I can to
help the team and yes I'll come back
stronger than before
[Music]
[Music]
when I come back in the summer if I
collect this time actuations they went
um I'm probably as much everyone so we
could time folks we'll get a landing by
stinking but it's not a subtle it get
the fun to douse online again amazing
double is collect one is rejecting as an
athlete you set up to go down as well
double it doc accuracy is it a really
fun the back ends the fight around don't
look look and keep it on some pieces for
big legendas once out of the way
stop sneaking the next box holes at this
Vivian's all plucked and for gets
another kill not business trying to keep
him out little hooks sings its are for a
little too long he's going to die that's
gonna be a kill over the summer being
able to smack them out of our some of
this you're going Lord good
straightforward even all showed us their
postures only to avoid the truth over on
top get a lantern thing from piglet and
ask him liquid still chasing under for
the town a butcher land it up all this
down that's gonna be the 851 but has
trouble in cross the triple kill there
are a saphenous man on the back end
right if I'm going to go down here and
loss against another open someone's and
Waller get a play clean of Apollo
lockdown she's got no a good to go and
double it gets another double kill
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button